on the corner of a street in jackson
mississippi don't let them kill your
child man america's reckoning with
abortion up close no uterus no opinion
they call this the pink house and for
the first full day since the fabric of
this nation shifted so dramatically the
clinic is busy
because these women arriving for
appointments they are among the last who
will come here
[Applause]
they must pass the gauntlet of critics
still here despite their victory
offering god and a choice of redemption
or hell sir is it sir excuse me is this
is this really the christian thing to do
to be you seem to be intimidating these
women who've got such hard choices to
make i'm intimidating them
do you think that what i'm saying is
intimidating to them well it's it's
compounding their their difficult
decision isn't it
well what we hope it's doing is pricking
their conscience
we believe that the child in the womb is
a human being created in god's image
and that to destroy that life
is murder
the pink house is where the supreme
court legal battle began and it is now
the last place where women can have an
abortion the last place not just in
mississippi but the last place across a
vast swathe of the deep south louisiana
has already closed
captioning not
[Music]
days the available here will be
triggered the clinic will close what
drives you to to be down here because i
believe in the constitution
what do you make of what happened
yesterday that was unconstitutional
all right how are you going to sit here
and take states rights away from one
state saying everybody can carry around
an extension of themselves i.e a gun
but then turn around and take the
federal rights away from women and turn
it back to the states
all right
doesn't make any sense
so yeah i hope everybody enjoyed the
constitution that we have for 250 years
because we don't have it anymore
i'm done
the decision in washington is prompting
profound questions for this country
about its unity its stability its
democracy but here where the impact will
be felt so greatly the questions are
much more fundamental
it's about choices of health care of
life being taken away
natalie collier supports some of the
poorest and most vulnerable in this city
this is a conversation about control
[Music]
and
black women who are historically poorer
live in communities that don't serve
them well
are going to bear the brunt of it
so what now
it's about
finding ways to subvert the system to
take care of folks in community
it's about
doing things
i'm trying to find a better way to say
take care of people illegally if that
that's what needs to be done
that's the nub of it the consequence in
the end will be to drive abortion back
underground
mark stone sky news in jackson
mississippi